make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and do
you all remember when we used to make up
our what-if stories I don't remember if
we did that many of them I know we did
what if Red Hulk became a Red Lantern
and I know we did what his Batman became
venom but I don't know if we did any
others besides those but like you guys
have constantly been asking for more of
like these what-if stories because
here's the here's the thing Marvel does
have a what-if line of comics right
those you guys weren't familiar with
this Marvel really used to have a title
called what-if right they basically
looked at alternate reality versions of
the stories that existed in their main
universe which basically allowed them to
be more adventurous in the stories that
they told because the what-if stories
did not take place in the main Marvel
continuity right so it was like what if
spider-man stayed then of what if
Punishers family had not been killed
that was the kind of stuff that we saw
but making up our own what-if stories
allowed us to do stuff the models never
done yet right like neither Marvel or DC
I've ever even done yet right with DC's
Elseworlds with Marvel's what is so we
can make up our own thing which is
always kind of fun and so in this video
we're gonna be covering what if Thanos
got all the Lantern rings in the DC
Universe what if you went to the DC
Universe and gained all the Lantern
rings now danus is a character that we
always associate with his quest to
collect all the Infinity stones it makes
sense for an interesting proposition for
him to basically want to also collect
another set of items that would grant
him even more power than he already
possesses but I think that we need to
start with wife a knows would want to do
this in the first place what's going to
be as motivation for collecting these
rings is he just like a jewelry
aficionado one into like add some rare
pieces to his collection is he trying to
flex on folks they see me rollin they
hatin patrolling they trying to catch me
ridin dirty trying to catch me ridin
dirty tryna catch me ridin dirty I don't
know that's and that's what he's wanted
to do right that would be awesome
I just like that much like rolling
around and like some some Cadillac with
like pink leopard skin on the seats and
stuff like that that'd be baller right
let's like up fallen Thanos I remember
seeing an image like that floating
around somewhere where he was just like
blinged out it was insane why do you
look like it he looked like a rap artist
like it was it was absolutely insane but
I think that what makes the most sense
here for this story is to play on Thanos
infatuation with death and his constant
struggle to win her approval I picture
this starting out with
conversation between the two of them
with Thanos basically saying that he's
killed all that he can in the entire
Marvel Universe and asking what else he
could possibly do to win the hand of
mistress death and so it's then that she
informed stano's of another universe
with billions more souls to claim for
her and then opens a portal to the DC
Universe now I know it's not the
strongest instance where I thought the
strongest thing to go with just go with
it
right that would never happen you know
like it's coming books right like The
Incredible Hulk being able to breathe
underwater was never able to happen
until it did right so like just roll
with it just have fun with this but
Santos would basically step through this
portal and did we flash forward to the
present where we find that Thanos is on
a ship with Sinestro onboard and what we
find out is that Thanos has been in the
DC Universe for months and has not only
learned of the existence of the Lantern
rings but has also decided to acquire
them all thinking that doing so will
make him a White Lantern thereby
granting him immense power and
increasing his ability to cause death
and destruction and in doing so finally
win him favor in the eyes of mistress
death so to help him accomplish this
task he enlists the help of Sinestro
who's made a deal with Thanos in
exchange for a promise that the mad
Titan will help him obliterate the Green
Lantern Corps and so we also learned
that their alliance has already paid off
with Thanos having acquired three of the
Rings already and we basically end up
getting these flashbacks where Thanos
had basically left the star sapphires
the Indigo tribe and the Blue Lantern
Corps in complete ruin
noting that he was able to overwhelm and
defeat each of them without much trouble
at all and so at that moment Sinestro
would chime in and say that would not be
the case with your next foe and he
basically explains to Thanos another
travelling to the homeworld of the Red
Lantern Corps to confront their leader
Atrocitus now undaunted Thanos would
basically tell Sinestro to set a course
for the Red Lantern homeworld and so
when Thanos arrives
Atrocitus is basically there waiting for
him and we get to see our first epic
fight of the issue with Thanos and
Atrocitus doing battle now as you may
know the Red Lantern ring is powered by
rage and Atrocitus has that in spades
and is able to basically mount a
substantial fight against Thanos
but as strong as he is he pales in
comparison to the power of Thanos and
ultimately falls in battle and so Thanos
would take the ring of Atrocitus and
make his way back to his ship where he
would essentially remark that the
this ring granted were quite impressive
and then imagine what a more worthy
being could do with such a weapon and so
Sinestro would provide a little bit of
an insight there and basically say that
it's powered by rage and Thanos would
basically reply by saying that's
something that he's not in shortage of
right and so semester would say good
you're gonna need it to take on large
fleets and so then we get to Thanos and
Sinestro landing on the planet of okara
the homeworld of Larfleeze himself the
only orange lantern in existence now
once Bannos steps off his ship he's
immediately attacked by Larfleeze
triggering another epic battle for
Thanos now much to Thanos surprise
Larfleeze presents even more of a
challenge than Atrocitus being able to
channel the entire energy of the orange
central power battery itself now the to
fight for a pretty lengthy amount of
time right they would need to given the
amount of power that Larfleeze has with
Thanos who basically be using the red
powering the entire time but Larfleeze
is essentially able to match him
blow-for-blow
and then suddenly out of nowhere
Larfleeze his ring would basically shut
off and Thanos would capitalize on the
opportunity to take his life as well as
his ring and so asthenosphere ound he
would see Sinestro wielding the blue
power ring and the Sinestro would
basically explain that the ring has the
ability to negate the effects of the
orange power ring and then of course
they also be kind of pissed off and be
like why didn't you tell me that in the
first place as listen master we'll
probably be kind of a dick about it and
just be like I grew bored and I figured
I'd get in on the action if the
opportunity presented itself later on
Sinestro would overhear Thanos seemingly
talking to himself as he passes by his
quarters and that would stop to listen
and it would become clear that Thanos is
talking to somebody else bragging about
the great warriors that he's slain in
her name but then also remarks that he
believes as Sinestro is withholding
information from him and does not
believe him to be as trustworthy as he
first seen as to the next day
Thanos his ship would hover over Allah
which was of course home to the Green
Lantern's such a power battery and he
would ask Sinestro like is the Green
Lantern Corps here and so Sinestro would
reply and just be like well they will be
the moment you attacked the central
power battery the Green Lantern's were
rushed to defend it and of course you'll
be able to crush them of course now
danos feeling like Sinestro was a bit
suss would basically say well I mean I
don't have all the Rays yet and like I
was supposed to wield the power of the
white lantern before I launched this
attack right and so Sinestro would hold
out his hand and open it and in the palm
is a yellow Lantern ring and would
simply just say Mike
to you by my calculations there will be
dozens perhaps hundreds of green
lanterns here any moment and so surely
you can relieve one of them of their
ring right and so Thanos would land on
OA
and make his way to the central power
battery and as he draws near he stopped
by a detachment of around half a dozen
green lanterns who basically tell him to
get back on his ship and leave and more
of them are on their way and this is one
one of the coolest moments right Thanos
is known for trash-talking and so he
would basically say when they get here
maybe you can use your rings to fashion
a green shovel to dig the graves of your
fallen comrades it's an awesome line
isn't that awesome that would be amazing
right so the Green Lantern's are
basically ready themselves for battle
and they would fight valiantly but now
in possession of the yellow orange and
red ring Thanos would prove to be too
much for all of them and so as the ring
of one of the Fallen Green Lantern's
goes to take off and try to find a new
host
Thanos would grab it seize control of it
and basically dominate the will power of
the Ring and make it his own
and then basically say the final piece
he needs to finish his collection and
harness the power of the white lantern
would essentially make him the most
powerful being in the galaxy and so once
he puts on the ring nothing happens
right and so at that moment danos is
confused and angry and then sees a
Laughing Sinestro and so if the arrows
would be kind of pissed off he'd be like
your treacherous fool like what have you
done and Sinestro would say I have not
done anything that Titan it's your own
shortcoming to betray you acquiring the
power rings alone will not make you a
white Lantern you must master all the
emotions of the spectrum to wield that
kind of power
wrath fear avarice even willpower you do
not lack but hope love and compassion
these concepts are foreign to you and
the power you desire will always evade
your reach now predictably Thanos would
be pissed
rightly he'd be mad as hell and he would
head towards Sinestro but Sinestro would
basically point to the sky where
thousands of Green Lantern's are
entering Oh his atmosphere and so of
course Sinestro would tell Thanos or he
would ask him
sixth Green Lantern's were not enough to
stop you but six thousand even a being
as powerful as yourself will not be able
to withstand their assault and so Thanos
would ultimately know that Sinestro is
right he would know that he basically
has to leave Oh immediately but of
course before he does he crushes the
head of Sinestro with his bare hands and
retribution for his betrayal before
getting on the ship and essentially
leaving now as the ship takes off the
green land
would land on Ola and Hal Jordan Jon
Stewart Kyle Rayner and all the familiar
faces would be among them now of course
Jon Stewart would look at Fano sleeving
instantly say we're too late and Hal
Jordan would respond he'll be back and
we'll be ready for him
here we cut to Thanos seething on a ship
but then we end up hearing a voice that
comes out of nowhere right and just
basically says vanos of Titan you have
proven yourself a great warrior and a
conqueror of death come to me and I will
give you power beyond your wildest
dreams right so Thanos is like who the
heck is this who am I talking to and
this voice identifies itself and says my
name is Necron but you can call me death
how awesome is that
right so Necron would basically go on to
explain that he is the counterpart of
mistress death in the DC Universe and
since Thanos has been dead and come back
to life he offers him a Black Lantern
ring which he'll basically use to
collect more Souls than he ever thought
possible now of course Thanos would
basically accept this offer as he's
completely obsessed with death and
figures that once he is basically
extinguished all life in the DC Universe
Death will finally move him out of the
friend zone and so Thanos takes the
Black Lantern ring goes to several
planets and lays waste to all of them
building himself an army of reanimated
corpses before he returns to OA to
finish off the Green Lantern's once and
for all now what we end up finding out
when he arrives
is that Sinestro had begun working to
sabotage his plan from the moment he
heard him talking to death and figuring
out that Thanos was eventually going to
betray him Sinestro had contacted Hal
Jordan and told him of Thanos his plan
to unite all the Rings and correctly
predicted that Thanos would fail and
then would ultimately discover the
existence of necron and the Black
Lantern Corps due to his fascination
with death and so Sinestro would tell
how that he knows what to do and how
would agreed and so when Thanos would
land on OA he'd be met by basically the
entirety of the Green Lantern Corps but
with his army of the undead with him he
would basically have the numbers
advantage and so the Green Lantern's
would fight valiantly but Thanos forces
are essentially gaining the upper hand
until house freezes plant and trades his
Green Lantern ring for a yellow one Kyle
Rayner would trade his Green Lantern
ring for a blue ring and Guy Gardner
would trade his ring for a red ring and
so Thanos would see this and then mock
them all derives
right stating that he basically killed
red yellow and blue lanterns and would
have no trouble doing it again and so
that at that point Hal Jordan would
chime it right and he would say you have
learned to wield the Rings but you don't
understand him
right you are powered by death itself
but we control the light and light
always drives out darkness and so the
group would essentially work in tandem
with green blue red and yellow fighting
side by side against the black lanterns
and mush Nathanael surprised he would
end up losing control of his forces and
so how would then monologue while he's
kicking the crap out of Thanos and we
basically say that he knew that the
Green Lantern's alone could not win the
fight but that when will power is in the
presence of one or more of the other
rings the effects of the Black Lantern
ring can basically be negated and so we
called upon members of the Green Lantern
Corps who had wielded other rings in the
past and asked them to do it once again
in order to stop vanos and save their
homeworld and so after a hard-fought
battle the lanterns would emerge
victorious destroy Thanos his black
power ring and then imprison him within
the central power battery on OA so that
he could probably break out in battle
the Justice League in a future storyline
and so the story will basically in felt
like back in the main Marvel Universe
mistress death would be calling up
Deadpool to see if he's still single
as her calendar has recently become
unexpectedly open that's how I see this
playing out right let me know you guys
think down in the comment section I
think is awesome I think it's like an
awesome idea let me know you guys think
but we're not being said we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as explained and make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the robb cork if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
purchase
[Music]